incredible geological features
beautiful coastline new zealand's maori
culture on full display
and friendly faces everywhere
welcome to the bay of plenty
national geographic sent my colleagues
and me to rotorua and fakitani
to discover what makes this part of new
zealand's north island
so unique photographer erica larson
visited
tepua a center for maori culture and
geothermal wonders
to explore kiri please tell me about
this
this amazing really really magical place
so we have so much to offer here rotorua
you know
forests lakes walking and also
experiencing our beautiful geothermal
around the city here rotorua
and the people and the people
and our geyser is ready
i found through my work wherever i go
there's always a guide it might not be
an official guide but it's always a
guide
that that can translate and introduce
and allow you to feel a landscape so so
your job here is really important
it is in my family there's four
generations who have all guided
we have become kaitiaki or guardians
of all the areas so it's our
responsibility
to take care of our whenua to take care
of our land
when i'm walking along this pathway here
i'm walking on the same path as my
ancestors
and when they guided visitors through
the area here it's just something that
came naturally
so you would say the knowledge is it's
it's natural knowledge
it's here you know it by living by just
experiencing it and living it
it's beautiful it's so beautiful yeah
for me
there's so many moments in the world
they're so loud and you come here
and you can feel you can feel a little
more human
yeah exactly right you get all sorts of
visitors when they're going on a guided
tour and then
they're going wow this place is bigger
and then what i thought it's not just
something that i see in a book i can
feel it
i can touch it they do go away
leaving here to puya as part as my
whanau
as part of my family because that's who
i
am
[Music]
meanwhile artist and author christoph
niemann
visited the national carving school at
tupuya where the traditional methods of
maori carving
are taught so we're here in the
only traditional maori carving school
yes
formed in 1926. oh so that that's
the 1926. what happens you start with a
say you start with a story so it means
like the beginning of carving is
speaking
and telling stories exactly and
listening to songs
listening to karakia prayers it all
contains
history in the process of coming it's a
lot of repetition
it's kind of like attention but it's
also you know it's really like the
manual labor
and like getting to know and feel for
the for the wood
do you remember a moment where i felt
okay there's
i start to have a connection here it's
when you realize that sound is
everything sound
yes so it's about the sound of the work
of the chopping
yes so it's
and and that you so through the sound
you get a feel for the wood
reflections your mind okay so that you
can
actually carve and so it becomes a
rhythm yep
so it's about rhythm pulse and your
heart
settles into that rhythm
[Music]
what are we looking at but it's very
very impressive
it's a memorial post that was meant to
celebrate the
100th landing at the gallipoli peninsula
this one is about the technicalities of
war
this is about the victims of war so it
goes from the very
um kind of tangible here into like a
more abstract uh
spiritual world okay what are the best
reactions that you get
from travelers from far away places or
from from from closer places
there's this idea that you come here
everybody's dressed on a pew pew and you
know they've
been here forever and a day but no most
of us have ancestors that have come here
trying to find heaven
all sorts of things there's a connection
from the world coming here and then
and that's that's what kiwis are yeah
they're a mixture of a whole lot of
people that have come through this
uh to this country but this is beautiful
and
it's it's interesting to look at the art
through that angle and i think also
coming as a visitor and
looking at it through this angle yeah
thank you you're welcome
[Music]
up the road from rotorua is ohope beach
i took a walk along the water and a
coastal track nearby
to meet my fellow explorers and some
friends for a very special dinner
[Music]
i take this coastal walk that's
absolutely stunning you know every
10 stairs or so you have a lookout
that is giving you a view of you know
these
mountains in the background that are so
they're almost it looks like a
watercolor
wow endless it feels like just
water that goes on forever
hey everybody thank you good to see you
curtifano really good to have you here
at the kaputerangi
the home of toy kairako our famous
ancestor so toy would have occupied this
place
around a thousand years ago um aohangi
is just about ready our feast
[Music]
yourself
[Music]
this looks fantastic can you tell us a
little bit about the hungi
yeah so the hangi is obviously our
traditional maori way of cooking food or
feasting
ours is unique as far as i know because
we actually
set the hangi in the ground and bury it
over so it's actually subterranean
ha is breath or also flavour
and is a very old word for
to burn to make smokey to make fire
so that's the origin of the word hangi
so the flavor
that is smoky has been burnt
so today when we came up the first thing
you notice inevitably is this beautiful
island here can you tell me a bit about
it
yeah so that island is mautohora the
island is now pest-free
it's a protected wildlife reserve neil
here is actually
heavily involved yeah so there was a
whole bunch of work if you look at old
pictures of motuhora
actually it didn't even have very many
trees on it the department of
conservation
and the ewe national worked really
closely together
there's a whole bunch of trapping and
work that was done to make it
make it pest free a lot of our native
birds and
animals in new zealand evolved without
mammalian predators
so motahora because it's pest free we
have birds on there that are actually
extinct
on the mainland
delicious everything is good the food is
absolutely wonderful
can you tell us a little bit more about
your history of cooking and
what we're eating here um my father
always instilled on us that a
well-fed body is a well-fed mind and
spirit
and if you really love what you do as in
cooking
it'll show and it'll always taste lovely
in your food that's wonderful
that's and that's what our food
[Music]